In July 2017, Milana Vayntrub was cast as
Marvel superhero Squirrel Girl in the new
Freeform comedy series, New Warriors.
And while you might not recognize the actress's
name, her face should be familiar.
From TV roles to web series, plus a certain
gig with AT&T, here are all the places you've
previously seen future Squirrel Girl Milana
Vayntrub.
"Drop the money, scuzz-bucket, or face the
wrath of Squirrel Girl!"
A start on television
Vayntrub landed her first memorable TV role
as a child, playing an HIV-positive Russian
girl named Tatiana on the classic hospital
drama ER in 1995.
Carol, played by future Good Wife star Julianna
Margulies, wanted to adopt the girl, but it
didn't work out, and Vayntrub left the show
after three episodes.
From there, she went on to small roles in
Days of our Lives and Lizzie McGuire — but
once the Internet came into play, things got
more interesting.
"How do you like, h-how do you, H-h-how do
you like them apples?"
"Uh."
An online star
Milana Vayntrub's most famous work online
came as the costar of the internet series,
"Let's Talk About Something More Interesting."
Along with fellow actress Stevie Nelson, the
2011 series featured Vayntrub conducting intentionally
terrible interviews with celebrities like
Matt Damon.
"Hi, hey."
This was also when Vayntrub started appearing
in College Humor projects, including the "Jake
and Amir" series, as well as a famous public
service announcement about Bitchy Resting
Face.
"That might just be her bitchface, and that’s
okay!"
AT&T
In 2013, Milana Vayntrub scored the role that
would define her career for years to come:
Lily, the friendly and patient wireless store
clerk in a popular series of commercials for
AT&T.
Lily is a little awkward, lightly sarcastic,
and occasionally flirtatious.
She's more girl next door than spokesmodel,
like someone you might actually encounter
working in an AT&T store…well, if you were
lucky.
As Lily, Vayntrub has shared scenes with regular
wireless customers, as well as celebrities
including Gordon Ramsay and James Van Der
Beek — and her natural charisma was surely
the key to the campaign's long run.
"You should negotiate more stuff, you're pretty
good at it."
Key and Peele
In a role as different from her perky AT&T
persona as possible, Vayntrub made a mostly
silent but highly memorable appearance on
the 2013 Halloween episode of Comedy Central's
sketch series Key and Peele.
She's nearly unrecognizable asthe gorgeous
vampire girl hanging on the arm of Jordan
Peele's gothic lord of the undead, who gets
called out by a new member of the vampire
gang for making mealtime weird.
"I'm just saying, y'all over here licking
and hissing and whatnot.
If we gon' eat, then let's eat, damn."
Although if you stick around to see the vampires
get a makeover at the end of the sketch, Vayntrub
looks a little bit more like herself.
House of Lies
In 2014, Vayntrub appeared in the Showtime
series House of Lies, in which she plays Christy,
a consulting firm employee who's both fired
and arrested after stabbing her boss Monica
Talbot, played by Dawn Olivieri.
Although she only appears in two episodes,
her memorable performance showcased yet another
very different kind of character from the
one she played in those AT&T ads.
Silicon Valley
You also might have spotted Vayntrub on HBO's
Silicon Valley.
Her character, Tara, is the girlfriend of
Martin Starr's cynical Bertram Gilfoyle — and
like Bertram, Tara is a practicing LaVeyan
Satanist.
Other Space
Created by Ghostbusters director Paul Feig,
this 2015 series was part of the launch of
Yahoo's streaming service, Yahoo Screen.
Vayntrub starred as Tina Shukshin, a flighty
and unpredictable starship navigator.
Unfortunately, Yahoo!
Screen failed to generate profits for the
struggling company, and the whole thing was
shut down in early 2016.
"That's the spirit."
Love
Vayntrub also had a crucial if short-lived
role in the first two episodes of Love, the
Netflix original series.
She plays Natalie, whose messy breakup with
Gus, played by Paul Rust, sets the events
of the story in motion that lead him to a
happier, healthier relationship.
Can't Do Nothing
Before she was an actress, Milana Vayntrub
was actually a refugee, having fled the USSR
with her parents in the 1980s.
"The Soviet Union is finally allowing thousands
of Jews to emigrate flee their lives of religious
persecution."
With her status as a celebrity, Vayntrub found
herself in a position to help other refugees
around the world.
In 2016 she founded Can't Do Nothing, a charity
dedicated to helping displaced people from
Syria and elsewhere.
Amid a turbulent presidential election in
which the refugee crisis was an ongoing issue,
it made news that "the AT&T girl" was involved
on a personal level.
This Is Us
Milana Vayntrub's most visible role to date?
It's her eight-episode arc on the massively
successful NBC drama This Is Us.
She played Sloane Sandburg, a playwright and
romantic interest for Justin Hartley's Kevin
Pearson.
Sadly, because the show is essentially a soap
opera, their relationship ended in dramatic
fashion — as did Vayntrub's work on the
show.
"It's the right thing to do."
But high-profile guest roles like this one
lead to bigger things, and it's not surprising
to see Milana Vayntrub move on to New Warriors.
Sure, right now it feels like she'll always
be Lily from those AT&T commercials — but
soon, Squirrel Girl might be the reason why
everyone knows Vayntrub's name.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!